following that monumental supreme court
ruling women in at least eight states
can no longer get a legal abortion many
more states are expected to outlaw or
severely restrict the procedure in the
months ahead now that would establish an
abortion-free zone stretching for
thousands of miles in the middle of the
country meanwhile the latest cbs news
poll shows that a solid majority of
americans 59 percent do not like this
high court's decision they disapprove of
it that includes nearly seven in 10
women also a majority 52 percent in our
poll say that reversing roe v wade is a
step back for america at large
jan crawford is outside the supreme
court for us uh jan good morning to you
we mentioned the shock the outrage
confusion what happens now
well good morning tony you know in
overturning roe versus wade and letting
states decide how they're going to
handle it we now have a patchwork of
laws so the right to an abortion depends
on the state that you live in abortion
has been one of the most divisive issues
of our time and we saw those divisions
on full display across the country
protests erupted across the country
after the supreme court's historic
ruling to end the constitutional right
to an abortion
with the ruling at least eight states
have placed near total bans on abortion
and within months it could be illegal or
severely restricted in almost half the
states in the country a victory for the
rule of law and above all
a victory for life
in illinois saturday former president
trump celebrated the news and the three
conservative justices he nominated to
the court who voted to overturn roe
those prayers have been answered to the
generations of americans in the pro-life
movement as well as countless
conservatives democrats warned of the
impact in states with already high
maternal mortality rates and children in
poverty this is not just a crisis of roe
this is a crisis of our democracy
forcing women to carry pregnancies
against their will
will kill them
republican governors like south dakota's
christie nome say they are prepared to
help women with more support and new
programs while also working to stop
women from getting abortion pills
through the mail in south dakota we've
already had a bill pass
that said on telemedicine abortions that
we don't believe it should be available
because it is a dangerous situation for
those individuals
without being medically supervised by a
physician
democratic governors where abortion will
remain legal said their states will
welcome all women for abortions while
others said they would work to make sure
it's legal this is a fight like hell
moment we are taking using every tool we
have to fight for reproductive rights
for michigan women
meanwhile confusion and concern about
how the ruling might impact other rights
in light of justice clarence thomas's
separate opinion which no other justice
joined calling on the court to
reconsider cases on contraception and
gay marriage
a majority of americans say they think
it's likely that the supreme court will
limit same-sex marriage and access to
birth control gay marriage
contraceptives
even though the court's majority said it
is hard to see how we could be clearer
that those cases are not threatened
because abortion is different because
they wrote it involves another life now
over the weekend the protests remained
largely peaceful and this isn't the end
i mean the court in coming days is going
to rule on other divisive issues
including religion in schools and
climate change vlad
this is not over yet jan thank you very
much